willkommen an der militärakademie wiener
neustadt ich bin oberst markus reisen
oder leiter der forschungs und
entwicklungsabteilung und heute wollen
wir uns in einem weiteren video den
verlauf der beiden offensiven der
indischen streitkräfte im oblast person
und hf ansehen mein team und ich haben
auch hier wieder versucht zu objektiv
und neutral eine lage darstellung
durchzuführen
beginnen wir ganz kurz mit dem
ausgangspunkt auch heute in unserem
video wollen wir vier faktoren
heranziehen und eine beurteilung
durchzuführen das ist dass einerseits
das gelände die eingesetzten kräfte der
faktor zeit und der faktor information
in den beiden räumen die von interesse
sind einmal in person und einmal im raum
haki
beginnen wir mit der offensiven person
beginnen wir mit dem gelände
inklusion stellt sich die situation wie
folgt dar die russischen streitkräfte
haben bereits am beginn des krieges es
geschafft über den stepper das westufer
des neckars in besitz zu nehmen seit
diesem zeitpunkt haben sie hier eine
stellung die sich von der mündung im
südwesten bis in den nordosten zieht
die wir kennen konnten hat er die
ukrainische seite es geschafft sich
tatsächlich mit kräften bereitzustellen
um hier die voraussetzungen für eine
offensive zu schaffen die
vorbereitungsphase war davon geprägt
dass man versucht hat diesen brückenkopf
zu isolieren man hat es dahingehend
durchgeführt dass man versucht hat die
drei wesentlichen übergangsstellen über
den fluss nebel zu zerstören das war
einmal eine brücke bei person dann eine
eisenbahnbrücke auch in unmittelbarer
nachbarschaft sowie bei einem kraftwerk
eine weitere brücke weiter im osten
diese drei brücken stellen nadelöhre für
die versorgung der russischen truppen da
die idee des gefechts war mit zwei
bindungs angriffen im süden und im
norden die russischen streitkräfte zu
binden und damit einen zentralen stoß
zwei kesseln zu verursachen zwischen dem
terror und den ukrainischen streitkräfte
in weiterer folge wäre sicher die
absicherung in streit gewesen diese
kessel dann zu zerschlagen
nach dem gelände sind wir uns kurz die
kräfte an hier kennen wir auf den
bildern dass die kräfte im wesentlichen
gestellt wurden sind durch westlich
gelieferte waffensysteme auf der einen
seite panzer vom typ c 72 aus polen und
tschechien
aber auch schützenpanzer von zum
beispiel die pnp
diese kräfte bilden die speerspitze der
angriffe an drei stellen des weiteren
hat sich das system heimat sehr effektiv
erwiesen im hinblick auf die zerstörung
der brücken aber auch der einsatz von
mobile artillerie wie hier das
politische system gab was er wichtig die
angriffe selber wurden vor allem aber
durch mobile einheiten vorgetragen die
es den ukrainern möglich machte relativ
rasch geländeteil in besitz zu nehmen
als beispiel für die wirkung gelieferte
waffensysteme vom westen sehen wir uns
im detail noch einmal den einsatz des
mehrfach raketen werfen systems und
heimat hier wurden circa 16 stück
geliefert möglicherweise sogar mehr wir
erkennen hier in dieser karte des von
russland besetzten teils der ukraine das
ist über 400 ziele bereits von der
heimat systemen angegriffen worden sind
das hat natürlich einen entscheidenden
effekt auf die logistik der russischen
truppen im folgenden video zeigen wir
ihnen die auswirkung eines derartigen
heim aus angriffes auf einen russischen
stützpunkt
kommen wir nun zum faktor zeit die
größte herausforderung für die
organischen streitkräfte bestand darin
die kräfte für einen angriff bereit zu
stellen hier war die herausforderung
dass die russische seite durch
aufklärung war mit drohnen sehr genau
wusste wo die ukrainische seite sich
bereit stellt das sehr offene gelände
bietet nur wenig schutz man erkennt dass
hier sehr gut dass die russische seite
ganz gezielt mit artillerie diesen
hätten streifen beschießt in dem sich
die ukrainische seite unter gezogen hat
man erkennt es auch hier bei dem bild
unmittelbaren angriffs beginn der
offensive wo man im hintergrund das
feuer der artillerie das einschlagen
erkennen kann
kommen wir nun zum faktor information
wir wissen dass die offensive am 29
august begonnen hat und zwar an drei
stellen sowie markus vermutet einerseits
mit bindungs angriffen im westen
beziehungsweise im nordosten und damit
den versuch eines zentralen vorstoßes
inklusive brücken so beziehe
flussübergang zentral in der mitte mit
der absicht hier zwei kessel zu bilden
nach der zerstörung der brücken in der
vorbereitenden phase aufgrund ist guten
lagebildes der russischen seite und weiß
offensichtlich möglich diese
angriffsspitzen der organischen seite
relativ rasche abzunutzen und bis jetzt
haben wir keinen signifikanten
vormarsch der ukrainischen seite gesehen
obwohl bemerkenswert ist in jedem fall
ein vormarschieren bereich person auch
hier im zentralraum und hier im
nordosten
das problem bei der weiteren entwicklung
der offensive ist vor allem auch hier
die aufklärung der russischen seite wir
kennen das in diesem video wo man
erkennt dass ein übergang über den fluss
in gohlis von den ukrainern gezielt von
der russischen seite beschossen wird
springen wir nun in den raum der zweite
offensive nach archiv wir beginnen auch
hier wieder mit dem gelände
dieser raum war geprägt von dem umstand
dass die russische seite nach wie vor in
der letzten woche monaten versucht hat
nach dem erfolg der kesselschlacht und
diese chance weiter richtung westen
vorzumarschieren es ist sogar so dass
ein weiteres chor das sogenannte dritte
armeekorps aufgestellt worden ist von
dem man annimmt dass es die absicht der
russen war aus dem raum ist schon in den
süden vorzustoßen und damit die
situation im donbass mit einem schlag
für sich zu entscheiden in dieser zeit
gab es immer wieder auch gerüchte dass
die ukrainische seite sich bereitstellen
würde im raum aktiv und tatsächlich war
es der fall dass die ukraine sowie in
person es geschafft haben kräfte hier
bereitzustellen das ganze unter der
höchsten geheimhaltungsstufe
und die beabsichtigte kräfte sowie auch
damals in den sozialen netzwerken
vermutet war es von hier richtung osten
vorzustoßen und bis an den so genannten
ost kiel fluss der die ukraine in die
lage versetzt hätte hier diesen raum mit
einem maler im besitz zu nehmen und die
russischen streitkräfte hier dann im
kessel pension einzukesseln
sehen wir uns um die kräfte an auch hier
kann man gut erkennen dass das material
das für die bereitstellung verwendet
worden ist vor allem oder ausschließlich
westliche ins militär material ist
einerseits haben wir wieder panzer vom
typ t 72 aus polen und tschechien aber
andererseits auch schützenpanzer vom typ
113 desweiteren mehrfach raketenwerfer
in diesem fall nicht heimat sondern mls
also auf ketten fahrende mehrfach
raketenwerfer aber auch systeme wie zum
beispiel diese fahren sowie 2000 die
sich eignet für den einsatz von den
phasen gesteuerte munition zentral war
auch hier der einsatz von hoch mobilen
einheiten zum teil auf pickups oder auf
diesen gepanzerten fahrzeugen dass die
moral dieser eingriff gruppierung sehr
hoch ist das zeigt uns das nächste video
das aufgenommen worden ist unmittelbar
vor dem beginn der gefechte wohl auch
einmal jüdischen soldaten zusammen
gekommen sind und ihre nationalhymne
gesungen haben
[Musik]
sehen wir uns auch hier einige spezielle
waffensysteme an die quasi erfolgreich
zum gelingen dieser offensive
beigetragen haben einerseits gibt es
klare indikatoren dafür dass bereits in
phasen gesteuerte munition vom typ
excalibur zum einsatz kam diese munition
hat den vorteil sehr zügig in eurem ziel
treffen können zu können dass andere
interessante waffensystem ist diese hand
ihrer der rakete vom typ a gm 88 mit dem
es die ukraine geschafft hat ganz
gezielt russische flieger pro systeme zu
zerstören und damit quasi das eigene
vormarschieren aber auch den einsatz der
eigenen luftwaffe auch wenn es in einem
geringen umfang durchzusetzen
schauen wir zu faktor zeit an die
offensive hat am sechsten september
begonnen und hat ein sehr günstiger
stelle sofort fuß gefasst und zwar an
einer stelle die von der russischen
seite eher stiefmütterlich behandelt
worden ist das heißt hier hat man eher
untergeordnete einheiten im einsatz
gehabt
dieser vorstoß hat sich dann relativ
rasch und wiegt und ist zentral in
richtung osten weiter vorangetrieben
worden
schlussendlich war es möglich eine
distanz von über 50 kilometer in sehr
kurzer zeit zu überbrücken durch diese
hoch mobil einheiten der ukrainischen
seite war es möglich dass diese die
ortschaften in besitz genommen haben
dort die ukrainische flagge gehisst
haben und diese bilder gezeigt haben
womit auch für die russische seite der
eindruck entstand dass sie zunehmend
umfasst werden und dass es das ergebnis
war war im prinzip eine flucht der
russischen streitkräfte in richtung
osten das problem ist nun wenn sie eine
grosse armee formation fluchtartig
absetzt dieses sehr sehr schwer diese
wieder aufzuhalten die russen haben das
einzige getan was an dieser stelle noch
möglich war sie haben versucht einen
sogenannten ost hilflos eine
verteidigungsstellung einzurichten und
hier die zurück flottenverbände
aufzunehmen dass diese situation sehr
prekär aber zeigt uns unterhalten um
dieses video wo man erkennen kann dass
die russen versucht haben mit der
schweren hubschrauber vom typ mi 26 zum
teil bis in die nacht hinein panzer an
zu landen und diese linie zu verstärken
auf der anderen seite kennen wir aus den
bildern dass hier sehr viel schweres
gerät zurückgelassen worden ist von
russischen seite
weil wir versucht haben mit den leichten
fahrzeugen sich rasch richtung osten
oder richtung süden richtung ist jung
abzusetzen sehen wir uns um den faktor
informationen der ukrainische angriff
wurde im kern vorgetragen durch zwei
mechanisierte brigaden eine luftstrom
brigade teile territorialer einheiten
und zusätzliche elemente zur
unterstützung die griechischen
streitkräfte sind sehr rasch
vorgestossen und haben es geschafft
richtung osten diesen angriff weiter
voran zu tragen das problem war nur noch
hier dass die russen ist nicht geschafft
haben diesen angriff schwung zu brechen
und damit quasi von den ereignissen
überrollt worden sind
das problem war dass dieser durchbruch
und tatsächlich war es ein durchbruch
über diese entfernung dazu geführt hat
dass die russische seite in panik
ausgebrochen ist und es war das ergebnis
dass nicht nur der abschnitt von der
durchbruch stelle weil die knie bis zum
osten fluss im besitz der ukraine
gelangt ist sondern auch der raum
nördlich von der stadt ist um
beziehungsweise vermutlich sogar bis zur
russischen grenze möglicherweise sogar
teile der russischen streitkräfte sich
nordostwärts vortag ebenfalls
zurückgezogen haben hier erkennt man an
diesem bild eine der brücken die von der
ukrainischen seite das stört worden sind
wo die russische seite versucht rasch
über diese brücken drüber zu gehen
wenn wir uns jetzt das ergebnis dieser
offensive ansehen so kann man natürlich
historische vergleiche heranziehen ich
werde das nun kurz versuchen es bietet
sich an als vergleich das unternehmen
cobra im juli 1944 anzusehen der
durchbruch der alliierten streitkräfte
aus dem brückenkopf in der normandie in
die tiefe des französischen tief landes
hier gelang es relativ rasch durch den
einsatz von zwei
gepanzerte und die visionen in die tiefe
vorstoßen und die voraussetzungen für
einen kessel im august dem kessel von
folle zu schaffen aus diesem kessel
gelang es der deutschen streitkräften
nur fluchtartig auszubrechen unter
zurücklassung einer hohen anzahl von
waffen ausstattung und gerät ein
ähnlicher vergleich bietet sich an mit
paragrafen im juni 1944 wo ist doch eine
massive nein f gelungen ist nicht nur
das russische seite voranzutreiben
sondern vor allem die deutsche seite in
eine fluchtbewegung überzuleiten die bis
nach der jetzt bis zur grenze des
deutschen reiches nicht mehr gestoppt
werden konnte auch dieses ereignis ist
theoretisch möglich es könnte aber auch
sein dass der erfolg der ukraine nur von
kurzer dauer ist so wie wir das in denen
offensiv und dezember 19 44 gesehen
haben das heißt man stößt vor ist aber
dann aufgrund der überlegenheit des
gegners gezwungen dieses gewordene
gelände wieder aufzugeben
möglicherweise ist es aber auch so dass
die erfolge der ukrainischen
streitkräfte dazu führen dass es in
russland selbst zu umbrüchen kommt
vergleichbar möglicherweise mit einer
situation wie im oktober 19 17 zwar gibt
es momentan keine indikatoren dafür aber
durchaus kann es sein dass die sich nach
dieser zweiten schweren niederlage es zu
diesen zerfallserscheinungen kommen kann
wenn wir uns die gebiete ansehen die
verluste in besitz genommen sind nach
wie vor zu sehen wir dass ich hinsicht
der creme aber auch noch hans nicht viel
verändert hat auch in den jetzt gelingt
es den russen nach wie vor langsam
vorzumarschieren
entscheidende unterschied ist nur im
raum h aktiv wo wir sehen dass
möglicherweise dieser gesamte raum in
besitz genommen worden ist aber auch die
vorsprünge die wir hier immer oblast
mikulasch beziehungsweise person sehen
das heißt dass in besitz genommen
gelände durch die russen verringert sich
weiter auf zumindest unter 20 prozent
versuchen wir nun die situation noch im
gesamten einzuordnen wir sehen also hier
die gesamtübersicht mit diesen massiven
ergebnis dieser operation der ukraine in
den letzten tagen was wir erkennen
können ist dass der konflikt jetzt in
eine neue phase übergeht die erste phase
war der angriff und die abwehr der
russischen streitkräfte im raum kiel
die zweite phase war das übergehen der
handlungs initiative an russland und die
angriffe im ton basis mit der
kesselschlacht von lisa chance die
dritte phase ist jetzt wieder
gekennzeichnet von einem neuen übergehen
der initiative auf die ukrainische seite
durch die offensiven bei person bzw bhp
von denen sich vor allem die offensive
bei akws sehr erfolgreich herausgestellt
hat
diese bilder zeigen erfolgreiche
ukrainischen soldaten im raum
südostwärts von hatif die offensive im
raum hat gezeigt dass die ukrainische
seite sehr wohl in der lage ist nach
einer zusammen sie und der gäste und
auch entsprechender geheimhaltung eine
offensive durchzuführen es hängt nun
entscheidend davon ab ob die ukrainische
seite diesen erfolg weiter ausbauen kann
das ergebnis werden wir erst in den
nächsten wochen und monaten sehen ob
tatsächlich eine wende in diesem krieg
herbeigeführt worden ist auch diese
frage wird sich spätestens in den
nächsten monaten beantworten
damit bin ich am ende unseres heutigen
videos die ursache dafür dass wir seit
längerem kein video gedreht haben liegt
darin dass ich vor kurzem die ehre hatte
die gerade in wien zu übernehmen die
garde ist der traditionsverband des
österreichischen bundesheeres
gekennzeichnet durch das rote bereits
dass auch ich jetzt trage und dem
wahlspruch ehre und pflicht wir werden
versuchen auch in zukunft das ein oder
andere video zu drehen jedoch meine
funktion als kommandant erfordert meine
volle aufmerksamkeit bei der führung
dieses verbandes ich bedanke mich für
das zu sehen und sagen auf wiedersehen